[Music]
so today we are going to do something
interesting you're going to deep dive
into something come back out go back to
the basics and then you get to question
the people who built some of the
technologies I'm going to show you so I
have the easy job today
so we'll see how that goes so let's
let's start thinking about some of the
trends that some of you are seeing in
your own Network sort of for your own
services one of our cloud customers for
example their entire service was a
single monolith and it used to take them
about three months to ship out a single
change and what they did is they took
this monolith and they chopped it up
into about 80 microservices and the time
to release something went down from
three months to a week so it's not that
people care about micro services or they
care about all of these technologies
what they really care about is what it
brings them the second trend which you
probably already noticed or are facing
or based on whatever deployments and
services that you have it's that hybrid
multi cloud and public cloud and Google
cloud are here to stay so and this would
be simply because you're migrating to
the cloud you're now going to make the
migration in one shot or it may be that
you want to actually keep some of these
systems on Prem
and then in the third case it could be
that you want to leverage the best of
every public cloud and whatever they
have to offer and so you may be
deploying your services on pram or in a
private cloud in Google Cloud in an
another cloud so the thing that we have
been thinking long and hard this last
year is how can we make it easy for you
to go deliver hybrid and multi cloud
services we are literally not toiling
over the infrastructure that's actually
needed to make this happen the first
thing that's actually needed to make
this is to remove like look at your
service you're essentially crafting each
service piece by piece today and the
first thing that you want to do is
remove all of the common core out of
your service this would be typically
networking code which involves load
balancing or there's a fault injection
or failure recovery it depends on what
all you're adding to your services
so what if we removed all of this and
then encapsulated it into a simple
component that you could just add your
services without bothering to write and
all of these primitives inside your
services themselves and in the second
thing is once you've done that who's
going to go manage all of these services
and that is where you need services
management infrastructure and it's
basically not something you want to
manage yourself so you want a fully
managed services management
infrastructure so I thought let's do
something fun let's actually go and
build out let's say a summer shop
because it's pretty hot not in San
Francisco but otherwise and if you think
of a typical web facing app you would
have a front-end and you'd likely have a
shopping cart service which is along
with your catalog and then you would
have some sort of a payment gateway or a
payment system so let's call this our
summer shop and we have our three
services typically a users traffic would
go in that order which is user -
front-end - shopping cart - payment now
one of the nice things that have
actually come to the forefront I would
say in the last one year or probably a
little bit more than that is this
concept of a service mesh so and you
will hear us talking about it a bit more
as we go throughout the session but if
you have to think of service fresh in a
very simple way it's like this so
imagine your infrastructure that existed
let's say ten years ago everything used
to be a one box and you bought it now
you're doing the same with services
everything is bundled together so what
service mesh is trying to do is actually
D couple that so if you look at your
let's say it's a port or a VM and on
there all you want to do is on your end
you just want to write the service
software and you want what you want
somebody else to do is to write all of
the common software which would be load
balancing which would be lets say
service authentication maybe you're
doing some sort of testing so timeouts
retries all of the failure recovery
mechanisms so that's what you see on the
bottom half of the service mesh what you
see a very critical component of this is
the service proxy which we'll talk about
a bit more
that's essentially doing a lot of the
heavy lifting of whatever your services
are doing today the service part of it
is simply you're either application
logic or your business logic and
the green thing that you see at the top
is your service mesh control plane and
this is the thing that's going to talk
to your proxies this is the thing that's
going to deliver intelligence to your
proxies this is the thing that's going
to absorb things related to
observability so if you had something
like this as you can imagine the gray
box is all you need to focus on and rest
of it is taken care by your services
management infrastructure now this is
where one ROI comes in and we are really
fortunate to have Matt Klein from lyft
here we will ask him all the tough
questions later but the Envoy proxy is
actually a very key part of this
infrastructure and if you think of the
service proxy that you saw in the
previous slide it's basically on why
that fulfills our function in here so we
use Envoy in addition to all of the
technologies that we already have which
is a compute engine kubernetes engine
you heard of GK on Prem and there's our
cloud load balancing so if you took a
closer look at Envoy what is it that you
see inside basically first of all this
was developed by lyft and it is also
battle tested it lifts so it's already a
hardened proxy and the things that we
really like about envoy first of all it
is high-performance need of coal
implementation then it also provides
eventually consistent service discovery
and we will ask Matt why that's
important then it's also API driven
which was really important to us because
we almost view it as an integral part of
our as you saw the service mesh and then
the service management story and it had
to be API driven for that to be
effective it's also extensible with this
notion of filters I'm sure Matt will
touch on it a bit more one of the nice
things is that several of these
protocols such as HTTP two are built
into Envoy so it supports them from the
get-go so that's again important because
that's what helps you bring in some of
the modernization into whichever
services that you have today and the
most important thing is it was designed
for observability a lot of times all of
us add in observability as an
afterthought and I think that is why a
lot of our services are these silos and
we really don't get an end-to-end view
so if you if you think about all of this
now this is what it would look like if
we added the proxy into our
services and you can see that now each
of our services these are either vm's or
containers whatever your favorite stuff
is and then we added a service proxy on
each of those instances that's running
each of those services now this is the
cool part so we are really excited to
announce traffic director our traffic
director is a new service which is going
to take away some of the toil of going
and managing all of these services so
like I said before what you really want
to focus on is your either
application logic or your business logic
and you want Google to basically take
care of the rest Google and then the
service proxy and so that is where we
are going with all of this so this is
now available in alpha you're the first
people who are actually hearing about it
so what exactly is it first of all it's
a GCP managed service then you can think
of it almost as an enterprise ready
control plane for all of the service
proxies we spoke about and the nice
thing is that you had a service mesh
which could extend to a zone we are
going to let you extend your service
mesh across regions so that is what like
you're very used to our global load
balancing with a single whip imagine
that you brought that same concept to
micro services and then you have the
same things that you get with global
load balancing as you get with our
external one the other nice thing is
that traffic director will also health
check all of your proxies for you which
means each proxy doesn't need to help
check each other so you have distilled
on the n square health checking problem
and you've just simplified an outsourced
that to the traffic director so I would
say like the two main things that you
want to think about our global load
balancing health checking its scale and
then the third thing is every like auto
scaling which is typically available for
all of our services so based on traffic
signals this will go and actually scale
your backends as well whichever ones are
running the service so if we add a
traffic director that is where it would
go to one of the things that we really
wanted to do was to use open api is
between the traffic director and the
service proxy and so we use the XDS v2
API s and we'll talk about those as well
and then if you look at this picture
essentially
the green box is managed by us and then
the proxy is the one that's taking all
of your networking code and then it's
sitting next to your application or
business logic and making things much
much simpler for you so I spoke a little
bit about global load balancing and what
does that exactly look like so this is
what we are going to go and look at
which is the service that we spoke about
I have three services the web front-end
the shopping cart and the payment if you
can see the first block that is
essentially your web front-end and these
are not two separate things one sitting
in Singapore region and one sitting
somewhere in the US this is actually one
service with just instances sitting in
these two different regions same for
shopping cart and then same for the last
service which is payment so what did we
do so far we put in a proxy we put in
traffic director and the moment we put
in traffic director we could go expand
our service beyond a single region
otherwise if you did it on your own you
would pretty much be in a single region
but traffic director enables you to go
and then spill over or even fail over
across regions so I thought let's take a
quick look at a live setup I'm going to
ask our folks to switch me to the demo
and we'll also pray to the demo gods can
you okay that's it so this is our
essentially our summer shop and we have
got some interesting things that we want
to sell including I just noticed this
morning a very expensive popsicle which
costs 300 bucks but what we what you're
seeing here really is that this is that
you remember we talked about the three
services and the first service is the
one that is in u.s. central this is our
front end service now let's try it let's
buy the expensive popsicle now that we
talked about it so if you now let's say
click this one and what you will notice
is this is the small blob EUR which is a
little bit cut off but that's our
shopping cart service again the
instances here are the ones in US
central and the reason is because I am
in I'm right here and our other set of
instances were in Singapore so obviously
the instance is in US central which is
an IO bar closer to me and then
obviously
mean we have a lot of money to spend so
let's go by the $300 popsicle and what
you will notice is that the payment
service that it went to is actually this
US central one see as well so if you go
back to the diagram I just showed you
before and let me show you the backend
of this a bit now one of the things
about the wavy setup is let's go back in
here so these are all the instance
groups these are literally the managed
instance groups running each of your
services so what you see in here
essentially is our the first thing that
you would see is our front end which is
two instance groups then the second
thing you would see our cart which is
two instance group one in each region
and then the third thing would be our
payment again one in each region and the
last thing is simply because I want to
masquerade as a client from Singapore so
that's just one setting in there but
what you would really want to look at is
go to network services and then look at
your load balancing and this is where
you would see three services and if we
go actually to the back ends you can see
that this is the front end service then
one of this one is a sense the BS one is
the shopping cart service and then the
last one is the payment service so this
is what it looked like when we were
actually accessing it from here and then
the last thing that we would want to do
we can try it live and see so I wanted
to literally do everything from scratch
so this service now this is basically a
client that's going to set in Singapore
and okay so maybe it's not connected so
there is a client that's sitting in
Singapore and what we really want to see
in here is with the client and Singapore
actually go in there and we'll see if it
wants to go there or not if not we'll
see it on the console okay so I think
that might be because it's their setup
but let's go back and take a look at
this one
so I wanted to actually take you back
again to when we were in the summer shop
if you looked at this one here what you
can see in here is these instances in
here the payment and South Asia so when
we come in as a client from South Asia
you would go back and first hit the
front end in South Asia and then you
would hit the shopping cart in South
Asia and then you would hit the payment
service in South Asia so I wanted to
switch back to the slides because I want
to show what that would look like can we
get the slides back okay
so why is that important and the reason
it is important is for this reason which
is if you look at if something were to
happen to let's say all of your
instances in the middle region if
something were to happen to that your
first service can actually go and
failover to the shopping cart that's
actually deployed in the second region
and then let's say there is something
that happens with the shopping cart
service in that region because for
instance it's just not able to scale up
then it would go and it can access the
service that's in the other region so
just like you're used to global load
balancing which is available for your
external services you get the same
capabilities with traffic director for
your own internal services as well and
this is some of the other config that I
abstracted out you generally won't have
to configure all of this by the time you
folks get to using this but they did
this is some under the hood
configuration where you essentially set
up traffic director for your services
and then you also went and if you see at
the bottom you can see the Envoy is
running on an instance so this is just a
snip of one of those instances so we
spoke about all of this and now we are
going to speak about something that
you've been hearing throughout this
conference which is a steer and if you
look closely at sto I think all of you
are mostly going to be familiar with sto
but what you get is service discovery
you get security instrumentation you get
trying side load balancing for those of
us who have come from the traditional
load balancing world it is a bit of a
change because you're always used to the
server side doing the load balancing and
here you have the client side that has
the intelligence to pick the right
back-end and then of course you have
things such as circuit braking and
you've got dynamic routing and so on so
forth again building on the theme of
observability you can do observability
end to end using sto and then you
obviously have MPLS based security and
several of the other features that
you'll hear talked about in these
sessions one of the nice things about
sto is that you can use it with
kubernetes
Jiki but you can also use it with VMs so
as you'd go transition your
infrastructure you can actually also go
and use it as a migration tool so you
could pretty much set this up with your
VMs and then as you chop up your
monoliths or as you containerize your
services you could just move them piece
by piece and then the other thing is R
this is what sto and envoy look like
together so same model there's a control
plane there's a data plane which is with
services service B and then the proxy
there so typically we use envoy proxy
but any XDS we do compliant proxy can be
used now if you just imagine this
picture and you put traffic director in
the mix what you will notice is this
that whatever capabilities you get out
of pilot you will you can put traffic
director there and that is one of the
main reasons we chose to keep the
interface between traffic director and
the proxies using open source API is
because in the future you you will be
able to just go substitute your open
source pilot using the traffic director
and then like if there is one takeaway
you probably took away from this
conference it's that Google Google and
Google cloud are all in on hybrid and so
we want your hybrid services to get the
same benefits that any of your GCP
services get which is specifically as it
relates to services management
infrastructure and so we want to provide
traffic director such that it can not
only manage the proxies and talk to the
proxies and provide global load
balancing for things in Google's cloud
but also for things on Prem so and then
this is the picture you probably saw in
the keynote day which is bringing all of
these pieces together and this is how
traffic director on Y and then some of
our existing technologies such as multi
cluster ingress which under the hood has
a global load balancer all of these fit
in together because you know at the end
of the day what you really need is not
point products that you stitch together
you need a whole suite of products or
rather a platform that can help you go
and build all of these like whatever
services you want to build whether it's
on VMs whether it's on containers
whether it's on frame in GCP another
cloud you should be able to do it the
same way with ease and then in a way
that takes away all the toil from your
end
so you know I took you through a
whirlwind tour of all of this I now want
to start with where this all began and
so please join me in welcoming Anna
berenberg from Google and Matt Klein
from lyft who I get the pleasure of
asking really difficult questions after
our talk or they will be available
outside to talk to you so feel free to
bring in your questions and I also
wanted to give a special shout out to
the people who helped me build these
questions these are all trout
crowdsource so I'm gonna probably take
one of the slow do you folks have a mic
okay I'll take this one
so let's start with the most popular
question I got asked so maybe let's
start with Matt Matt why don't you tell
us about yourself but the popular
question was not that it was it was tell
everybody one thing that they don't know
about you okay
hi everyone thanks for having me I'm
Matt obviously I've been at lyft for
about three and a half years where I
work on networking prior to lift I
worked at Twitter also in networking
before that worked at Amazon on ec2 also
I've been working in the infrastructure
space for over 10 years what's you think
one thing that people don't know about
me I have a very unhealthy obsession
with pickles and I've been known to eat
so many pickles that then I have to go
drink a bunch of water because I have
like a salt salt overdose so don't don't
give me pickles hi my name is Anna
berenberg and I've been software
engineer for 27 years in the last 20
years plus I work in networking industry
and I never wrote a line of networking
quote I always had interest in building
fault-tolerant high availability
distributed systems and process
management system management stuff like
that and then I joined Google twelve and
a half years ago and spent last nine
years in infrastructure and technical
infrastructure and without moving my
desk I moved into cloud three years ago
becoming responsible for cloud Lord
balancing and Google Lord bones
products one thing people don't know
about me I used to dance professional
and ballroom dancing we might have time
for that a danger so that you guys okay
so actually this question is for you
Matt let's start with you because I
generally assume that most people would
know about envoy and like you know what
the journey was but what we really
wanted to do was to a lot of people who
are very interested in hearing the
journey in your own words so like how
did unwise start and like what were the
exact problems you are trying to solve
how did it all begin sure um so I've
been I've been working on service
architectures for quite some time like I
was saying over over 10 years now so
I've seen how Amazon had kind of solved
these different problems that people are
facing how it been done or Twitter and I
think what I mostly tell people is I
think most people that are rolling out
micro service architectures
it sounds great we're obviously told to
go and do it for all of the human
scaling benefits but we sometimes gloss
over all the complexities that come from
actually doing that so I think a lot of
smaller companies that aren't Google
they go and they start to roll out micro
service architectures and they wind up
in a situation where they might get 10
or 20 services and then things start
getting really difficult because they're
facing common problems in networking
with observability and what we found at
lift which one I think a lot of
companies face is that they go from
their monolith they start rolling out
micro services and then the developers
don't trust the actual micro service
platform and you wind up in this
horrible situation where you have
services that people don't trust because
they can't debug them they don't
understand what's going on and then they
start adding code to their monolith
again so you're in you're in this awful
situation of having services that people
don't want to use and continuing to
actually use your your monolith so the
way that people have historically solve
this problem is using libraries so at
Twitter there was a library called
finagle Google obviously has a library
called stubby
and there's other companies that have
solved this and that library does a
bunch of common concerns around things
like observability load balancing
retries timeouts but the industry has
moved to a polyglot architecture and by
that I mean that the days of Java only
are basically over so people now are
building services and five six seven
eight different languages so building a
library in those eight different
languages that your company has to
support is is kind of a non-starter so
when I joined lift lift was having all
of these typical problems around
networking observability load balancing
this kind of aborted you know micro
service rollout and I I knew that we
could do a better solution and that was
this out of out of process proxy system
where we could put all of the
complicated logic in there and provide
that for every application language and
it kind of grew from there it became
very popular at lift it was solving a
lot of business problems and we
open-source envoy about two two years
ago and nowhere in my wildest dreams
would I have imagined that I be sitting
here right now and we'd be announcing
these products it's been pretty
incredible but envoy has been sweeping
across the industry so there's been a
lot of other folks that have had common
problems so how did you just decide to
open-source that like was there any big
agenda there's there's no big agenda but
to be totally honest I'm I am this is
kind of the second time that I built
envoy at least to a certain degree we
did something similar back at Twitter
and I I didn't I don't want to build
this again so so two two times is enough
yeah that's a good reason so I think I
mean Matt you bring a lot of expertise
as you build out on where and so on I
know Anna personally because I work with
her on the day to day basis and I have
seen how to do something similar as it
relates to services at Google and maybe
and I think what would be nice is if you
can you've been there Google for like 12
plus years and you know some of the
experiences that you had building out
services but then also about is too like
how did we decide to work honesty
or so and how does it fit in with
kubernetes and several of other services
as well so building I worked in the last
twelve years actually I joined I wanted
to work on Gmail instead I got assigned
to group doing load balancing and I
thought of fine I'll do one year and
I'll go do something and also I'm still
there why because it's such a
fascinating problem the problem the way
we solved it at Google it's actually a
control system that does a pretty
sophisticated service that does global
load balancing in a way that improves
quality of life for the services we
built for for example how do you protect
against the theory of death about how do
you figure out that not all queries or
requests at the same cost because some
queries are more expensive with another
how do you make sure your backends will
never overload all of that needs to be
thought through so the service
developers don't have to and they don't
have to build some sophistication
solution all they have to do is worry
about the business logic so with all of
that my focus always been on the control
side of a lot balancing and so when I
saw Matt unroyal proxy I realized that
this is exactly the proxy I wanted to
have why because it's API driven and it
it it's funny it had very similar api's
to the api's we had internally at Google
between the control plane system which
does global or balancing and the proxies
themselves so with that when the idea is
still of Easter came out sorry the
Triton traffic director is
traffic director it became a natural
substitution for a pilot because with
the same API is now we can build into
issue and make Easter available not only
within a single geeky cluster but make
it horizontal and make it available
across the whole GCP and on-prem and
multi cloud and in multi cloud when we
talk about global load balancing first
we were talking about Google services
then we start talking global load
balancing within a DCP and now when when
we're saying global it means really
global worldwide no matter where that's
where our aspiration is today we don't
have it but that's where we're going
with it that we're going to take traffic
director and make it 'lord balance
anything anywhere within a sto
environment or actually within a new
environment
sounds good so actually coming back to
you Matt we spoke I mean I just brushed
through a lot of technical details of
envoy I think a lot of people may not be
familiar with things such as filters or
I know that observability is built into
envoy can you describe like let's say
your top five features for which you see
all your users using envoy sure yeah I
think that's a common question recently
which is what why is on boy becomes so
popular I think there's a couple of
different reasons I think the API is
probably the number one reason I
actually when I look at from my opinion
one of the biggest technology successes
that I've seen in the last couple of
years it's actually proto 3 proto 3 in
my opinion has been pretty awesome just
in the sense that the ability to go from
a structured IDL to JSON llamó and back
and forth and that's how we do our new
configuration now so the API is the same
as the config it's just it's and it's
it's super seamless like you can use G
RPC in any different language you can
write config files and Jana land JSON
and it all works the same way and I
think people really love that so the
fact that you can control on boy either
through local config files or you can
serve everything over a central
management server it's super flexible so
I think historically with proxies like
nginx and H a proxy where people have
had to ship around config files and and
and that works fine but there's you know
at large-scale trying to manage those
files and make sure the updates take
place and and kind of figure out how to
do that from a deployment perspective
can be quite complicated so the API has
been very flexible and has been super
popular the other thing is the extension
capabilities so when I first designed
envoy I kind of base it on prior
experience and instead of making it very
HTTP specific I built it in a way where
it was an l3 l4 proxy
so basically bytes in bytes out and that
means that it could be used for other
protocols so it lifts today we use it
for MongoDB we use it for Redis there's
people now building thrift support my
sequel will do Kafka eventually and what
you'll find is that even in all these
protocol implementations there's a lot
of common core stuff around service
discovery health checking you know so
lots of common functionality can be
shared and then you can build these
protocols on top and then we also allow
extensions at the HTTP layer at the
stats layer at the at the tracing layer
so it's a pretty pretty rich platform
from an extensibility perspective so I
think from a technology perspective
those are the two main reasons third
reason is just from from like a
developer productivity perspective I'll
be honest in saying that kind of where
the first open-source proxy where we're
on github like we do CI we have a very
open community so I think people have
really loved the fact that we're very
easy to engage with and get patches and
so I think those are the big the big
three reasons and I know do you it was
similar to how Matt did a little bit of
deep dive into some of the features
can you you know whenever we say or we
have of like global load balancing for a
lot of people it's this vision of a box
or like a global box which is straight
like this huge thing I know it's not
that at all can you describe a little
bit about like what is this traffic
director thing under the hood like what
does the architecture look like so if
you if you think about traffic director
it has two interfaces one interface to
the proxy and it's open XDS api's and
they have several api's in them cluster
discovery service endpoint discovery
service listener discovery search route
discovery service health discovery
service eventually Lourdes reporting
service secret discovery service and I'm
running it so basically it's all the
communication that needs to happen
between between the proxy and the
control plane now on others another back
side traffic director has interfaces to
Google systems our proprietary systems
that actually do all that functionality
we have control system that has global
load balancing in a way that there is
nothing in the industry where we
actually load balance based on a
capacity of the backend so not we don't
do spray-and-pray
we actually count the queries the and so
we never deliver more than than customer
wanted us to deliver and then we had
Auto scale for example based on that
capacity so in addition we do
centralized health checking so what is
centralize health checking when I joined
Google one of the biggest consumer in
Google cluster was a health checking
because when the deployments get big if
you start doing an square health
checking the bandwidth consumed by
health checks is enormous so all of that
sounds like ah that's not a problem it
actually becomes like very boring boring
house checking becomes
massive problem because it consumes all
your network so centralized health
checking allows you to dedicate health
checker and health check all back ends
in a way that it's actually health check
you can trust the result the results are
getting merged and aggregated by control
plane and then they distributed with an
point discovery service same with auto
scaling we take all that data reported
through Lourdes reporting service and we
digest it and we translate it into the
demand that autoscaler needs to get and
we integrated without a scaler and the
autoscaler skills are based on traffic
demand so yeah and the funny thing that
I was telling Matt that our internal API
is actually matched very closely to the
Envoy api's and that persuaded me that
that's the right proxy to use sure yeah
you know I think that when when most
companies look at deploying a proxy like
envoy or like a tree proxy or nginx most
companies start with a fairly simplistic
control plane and if you even look at
what lyft does compared to what Google
does it's obviously a totally different
magnitude of scale so it's not
surprising that we do things in a far
less sophisticated way but what what I'm
so excited about just just this whole
general area is that just because of
this open API and the fact that people
are converging on this API it'll allow
companies like lyft eventually who
frankly are not going to be able or
really can justify building a control
plane as sophisticated as what Google
can offer we can just go and use that
control plane and I think there's tons
of companies out there that would
benefit from this type of technology and
you don't it doesn't have to you know
from a lyft perspective we can still run
our own envoys and still manage them and
still do what we want with them but we
can get you know far more sophisticated
functionality from a health checking
perspective from a subsetting
perspective than we would ever be able
to build ourselves so that's that's
or exciting that's awesome I think I
mean believer well both of you are
speaking like you were talking about
Google and lyft a lot of people here
have their own deployments which
slightly are on-prem many of your moving
or have moved to GCP and a lot of your
services are probably in VMs but you do
want to containerize them to get all the
benefits and then in all of this we
added things like envoy proxy is to your
traffic director so for people who are
starting out here at least or based on
your experience with your users
how do people bring in these new
technologies into a brownfield or
existing deployments that's that's tough
and it really depends on the particular
deployment I think what's interesting
from an envoy perspective is that
there's such a rich ecosystem of
projects that are kind of starting to be
built on top so obviously sto is super
well knowing there's a bunch of other
companies that are that are building
stuff on top so kind of what I tell
people these days at least from an envoy
or from a proxy perspective is that I
would not recommend that companies go
and build their own control plane like I
think at this point you know people
should be looking at sto looking at
pilot looking at other other solutions
that are out there just because there's
I think people underestimate the
complexity of building your control
plane I think people look at and they're
like oh how hard can it be I can get
some host information and send it to
envoy and things will just work and it
does do that in the beginning but then
as you start scaling up and you deal
with the end square at health checking
problem and you deal with security and
you know like service manifests and all
this other stuff it gets complicated
really quick so I think my
recommendation right now for people that
are looking into these solutions is to
you know not necessarily even look at
envoy directly but to look at some of
the stuff that people are building on
top and one of the things that I've been
seeing recently and I and I really
firmly believe is that it's really
amazing that envoy has become so popular
and it's getting very why
white uptake but at the same time I
think that in a couple of years though
envoy will be used in a lot of places I
think most people won't know that
they're using envoy like I think they're
going to consume it as part of other
products or other other systems so I
would definitely encourage folks to to
look at some of the systems that are
being built on top and what about you
what do you think I mean we heard this
all the time if you have customers
coming in with existing deployments and
let's say it's somebody who's running
their services in a VM
how would you ask them to start or where
would they start so from our perspective
we the configuration coming to traffic
director is done via TCP API and in the
future we add additional sto ApS but DCP
API is already integrated with the law I
mean those are load balancing API is
your provision provision other load
balancing products and what we've done
we usually use the same data model to
provision traffic director and on voice
the only difference is a one boolean and
so in my mind one it's easy if you're
already using TCP it's easier to add on
because it's just yet one boolean and
instantiation of an way also we are
going to be if because it's all
integrated traffic director essentially
becomes an centralized brain for all
your on plants everywhere so whether
you're you're configuring envoy which is
self manager maybe manager or some other
product that is going to be using olive
oil or any for that intent and purposes
any proxy that using the same API is we
can extend your existing deployment to
two eesti or ought to just envoy it
sounds good I actually wanted to give
because we want to hear from you so I'm
going to give you this hypothetical
scenarios let's think let's say three
years down the line I don't
five years so we'll go with three years
how do you like would we be talking so
much about pain points of delivering
hybrid services or do you think there'll
be a slew of products and platforms with
this being a beginning where it's just
it's just natural to have something
that's across clouds like how do you see
the world maybe three years from now
what kind of products technologies what
is the next thing you'll be working on
that'll help some of this stuff so you
know from from a three year perspective
that that's that's tough to say well
I'll talk a little more I think in the
in the five to ten year time frame just
in the sense that like I'm a big
believer in serverless technologies
server lists just in the sense that I
think most most application developers
they want to write business logic like
they don't want to worry about
infrastructure and the biggest thing
that I see in the industry right now is
that most companies are they're spending
too much time on a per developer basis
worrying about infrastructure like
worrying about how networking works or
observability or or databases so like I
I'm a big believer in the idea of
eventually people writing functions or
code snippets and eventually being able
to just ship those with that said I
think we're very very far from there
just because I think a lot of those
technologies their orders of magnitude
more complicated than than what we have
today there's just there's more auto
scaling there's more networking there's
there's more problems that that can
happen so where I see things going is
you know I I think that increasingly all
of the cloud providers not just Google
you know are gonna start offering more
integrated products where you know you
might not call it server lists it might
be container based but the idea is that
you know people are gonna expect a
certain set of technologies around
observability service discovery load
balancing rate limiting policy are back
and instead of having to worry about how
its implemented people just want to show
up and say I'm gonna use these features
so I'm biased
like I think envoy will be used to
deliver kind of those those use cases
but as I was saying before I don't think
many
people will end up knowing that it's
envoy it's actually doing that like
they're going to use integrated products
so right now from from a hybrid
perspective obviously we're gonna have
years of people who have on-prem or
multiple clouds but over time you know I
think we're gonna move to hosted
kubernetes and then from there we're
gonna move to like hosted function and
platforms and it's gonna be it's gonna
be a slow iteration but we just keep
adding more abstractions and hopefully
every year people have to deal less less
with infrastructure I probably want to
talk about even higher level of
abstraction I think in three years maybe
in five people stop configuring systems
there they are today we are api's we're
the CMO files and everything because
from we just we just need to not make
infrastructure I mean the service owners
to be having PhD in provisioning so all
we want to do is actually to move
towards imp and driven configuration
where the service can be described in
too intense do you want to have a
service latency optimized optimized
perceived user latency from from the
user to the front-end or overall serving
oh the the other one do you want to have
cost optimized service or do you want to
optimize towards transferring less less
data over a wire or something else these
are the configuration that will
internally translate into right
configuration because today with the
hundreds of knobs even if we do best in
tank you may not end up with intend you
want to have so we need to be able to
express intent very clearly in a
high-level and translated internally and
the second thing I think super important
to stop thinking about each micro
service separately we need to start
thinking about overall deployment and
how to have configuration
our policies that apply to overall
deployment how to provide consistency
coherency to make sure that if you're
talking about security policies you
don't have to go and configure on each
of hundred 18 micro-services all you
have to say I'm gonna provision it one
way and then it's going to understand
how to apply it everywhere in the
different ones however services deployed
and then it's actually then you can link
it into some recommendation engine that
that can say oh my god you didn't you
didn't provision something somewhere or
yours
you have vulnerability about security or
in general it can look at the deployment
and can say you can do better right
that's that's I think that's we want to
be in three five years so I think with
that we come to a close of this session
Matt and Anna will be here I think
probably outside the room so feel free
to reach out you know the nice thing is
a lot of these are very new technologies
and the reason we are talking about them
so early is because we do want each one
of you to influence these technologies
and we added a set of features that we
thought were table stakes but I'm sure
there are a lot more features that you
need on your end to make this just be
the tool to make your hybrid and mult
multi cloud deployment seamless so with
that thank you folks for coming and feel
free to talk to our two people and ask
them all the tough questions thank you
everyone
[Applause]
you
[Music]